I mean I've only worked with Gweneth one
time on spider-man homecoming but she
doesn't remember Holland is crushed
Gweneth Paltrow tuffet remember working
with him on spider-man homecoming well
we were a spider-man together remember
we're on spider-man we were in
spider-man yes we were to rub salt in
the wound
Tom revealed another nugget in the
PopSugar trivia game when it also worked
with Tom on Avengers endgame along with
Robert Downey jr. and here's what
happened and she came up and she asked
me for a photo with me and Robert and
then I think she posted it and she said
Robert Downey jr. and myself and this
guy
the viral Gweneth moment happened while
chatting with Jon Favreau on the debut
episode of the chef's show on Netflix we
were an in spider-man yes we were
homecoming you were in spider-man no
yeah I was in Avengers no avenge fighter
man also it's become remember especially
at the end and the and Tom Hollands
there and you're gonna walk out with a
press conference I'll give you the rest
that was spider-man that was spider-man
I have a roomful of people in there
waiting for some big announcement what
am I gonna tell them to be fair to
Gweneth Marvel actors are very
frequently kept in the dark about what
they're filming for example McKenna
Grace who played a young Captain Marvel
had no idea what movie she was in until
she watched it all I had with the sides
for the day and I'd be going through
them trying to decipher but a lot of
them was crossed out I was like dang it
I want to know what's happening cuz I'm
me is a huge Marvel fan that I am I was
trying to figure out what was going on
and major endgame spoilers but they told
all those actors at the funeral scene
you know the big funeral scene was
actually a wedding this is how about of
this for me I was told it was a wedding
I showed us on the wedding marry some
dude winning chubbier is
[Music]
[Applause]